salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format nous faisons en focus sur un
point précis du cerveau dans les
épisodes précédents vous avez proposé de
parler des raisons qui font qu'une
connaissance erronée s'ancre dans notre
cerveau c'est le sujet du jour
bienvenue dans matière grise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
dans cet épisode nous allons vivre
quatre expériences expérience une
tourner à droite ou tourner à gauche
l'expérience de calculateurs de génie
expérience 3 c'est à vous expérience 4
on fabrique un arc en ciel le tout avec
la présence très appréciée de emi
altesse vous avez compris qu'aujourd'hui
on va parler des idées reçues
mais ce qui va être passionnant c'est de
voir pourquoi et surtout comment l ines
d'ailleurs comment ça se fait que
certaines idées s'ancre si fort dans
notre cerveau est pourquoi il est si
dure ensuite de les éliminer
prenons quelques chose que nous savons
tous si je vide mon évier alors le sens
de l'écoulement va être différent selon
que j'habite au dessus ou en dessous de
l'équateur
mais il ya une question encore pire
c'est comment est-ce que l'eau coule
quand on est juste moi à l'équateur et
bien en réalité l'ol cool comme elle
veut et partout dans le monde on va
essayer de voir ça aujourd'hui avec emi
et ensuite je vous expliquerai pourquoi
notre cerveau adore croire à ce fait
complètement erronée en fait on va
tester l'idée reçue et me
est ce que tu as déjà entendu parler de
ça peut-être pas mais parfois on parle
du sens de l'écoulement de l'eau qui
serait différent suivant qu'on se trouve
au dessus de l'équateur ou en dessous de
l'équateur il tournerait dans un sens ou
dans l'autre
est ce que tu as déjà entendu parler de
ça ou pas du tout pas du tout ok je n'ai
pas envie de te mentir en fait c'est un
truc qui se dit chez les personnes
scientifique compas trophée science et
du coup c'est complètement admis en mode
c'est la force de coriolis tu vois et
expliquent qu'ils ont des arguments
scientifiques pour ça il s'avère que
c'est faux d'ailleurs sinon à l'équateur
c'est à dire que ça tournerait pas du
tout du parfait avec bonbons méga cool
panne du coup ça ces jeux on va créer un
typhon et on va prouver qu'on peut faire
un typhon dans ce sens là où dans ce
sens là dans cette partie nord de
l'équateur
parce qu'on est dans la partie nargue
les potins bah pas de temps en fait en
réalité émeutes un peu d'astuce sera
faire des typhons donc tu pour amasser
des gens en disant moi je fais un tifo
est ce que je peux y mettre une
hypothèse oui est-ce qu'on va créer un
typhon en enfonçant sa danse ah oui
c'est un joli titre déjà mais alors on
va pas l'on pense et on va on va
mélanger des choses ensemble
ici tu as un bock dos je te laisse loué
un box
ici on va te mettre une petite goutte de
colorant
ça n'a aucun rapport avec l'expérience
c'est plus joli ça marche pas du tout ce
que tu fais c'est violer en fait une
piscine c'est ma oui oui un peu mais
c'est violer et surtout j'ai un peu
d'eux parce que je suis un temps d'un
film s'appelait pour toi que tu dis un
buck
parce que là je n'avais pas le terme un
bocal moi quand j'ai parlé terme au lieu
de l'assumer j'invente un mot médias
l'air correct mais parce que c'est un
diminutif de bocal bien sûr dans les
quartiers après tout c'est très très
compliqué il suffit de prendre ça et de
le mettre dedans
donc ça c'est de l'eau savonneuse ok
tout simplement tout simplement
peinture perm tu sers bien et là tu vas
voir il ya un truc très compliqué pour
faire le typhon ce que tu veut secouer
comme ça et on va pourtant ils font
apparaître soit tu tourne vers la gauche
mais c'est étonnant est ce que ça dit
des choses sur moi et pas mal gré
beaumont typhon vas-y et moi je vais
prouver que je peux faire un typhon mais
dans l'autre sens du coup on regarde le
ciel beaucoup plus pas mais moi je
détruis débilement c'est un peu gênant
je peut détruire des villes phares
antibrouillard et bienveillant matin
j'ai envie de le faire tout le temps
mais regarde mais ces tronçons en vrai
ça marche trop bien
attends je vais dans le sens pourtant je
suis droitier a par contre on peut dire
être maladroite et peut-être plus fort
que le typhon de gauche ok votre album
oui c'est mon monstre si je puis me
permettre de violer en plus dans la
qualité du luxe on essaie bien mais
voilà je refais un dernier coup à gauche
pour casser cette idée reçue que amy le
connaissais pas mais en fait il ya le
beau cadix et moi je sais pourquoi ça le
bas ça marche
résultat on a on a prouvé que l'eau
pouvait s'écouler dans les deux sens sur
l'hémisphère nord c'est tout qu'est-ce
qui a appelé mois max verbe on va passer
à la suite quand même
la suite c'est quoi au la suite va faire
un truc champ mais avec ton cerveau met
vraiment en mode tu vas leur faire plein
de fois alors non je t'explique si je
vais je vais te dire voilà ce qu'on va
faire avec ta tête et toi tu vas faire
jamais de la vie je serai faire ça
inquiète en cinq minutes tu seras le
faire et tu vas faire hausser moi qui
fais ça messieurs hockey
j'espère qu'on a beaucoup d'attentes
cette légende urbaine vient d'une
confusion faite à cause des cyclones qui
donne bien l'illusion de tourner dans un
sens ou dans l'autre suivant qu'ils sont
au nord ou au sud de l'équateur
mais en réalité c'est une illusion c'est
parce que la terre tourne les vents eux
ils vont tous droite mais comme il
parcourt de très longues distances et
que la terre a tourné eh bien on appelle
ça la force de coriolis et on a
l'illusion d'un tourbillon
tout le monde s'est dit que ce serait
pareil pour le lavabo mais c'est faux à
moins d'avoir un lavabo de dizaines de
kilomètres de circonférence la force de
coriolis elle n'aura aucun impact sur
l'eau les seules choses qui auront un
impact c'est la formule lavabo peut-être
la matière du lavabo peut être le sens
d'écoulement de l'eau au tout départ qui
va donné la première impulsion mais
c'est tout mais pourquoi cette fausse
information traverse le temps de
génération en génération
avec la certitude que c'est logique et
donc que c'est vrai on rentre là dans
l'adn d'une idée reçue qui tient en
quatre points son apparente évidence
elle passe pas quelque chose de logique
et facilement démontrable
le point 2 c'est son côté agréable une
information très simple à retenir
ensuite en 3 c'est sa fréquence de
diffusion
on a l'impression que tout le monde le
sait et on parle facilement donc c'est
que c'est vrai et enfin son côté un peu
fun fact le côté savoir insolites
parfois anecdotiques qui fait que cette
information est amusante à transmettre
quand ces quatre points sont réunis une
idée reçue solide peu vite émergé et
aujourd'hui je vous préviens
exceptionnellement cet épisode est
sponsorisé par moi même il n'ya plus de
surprise
juste un homme qui peut vous apprendre à
gouverner l'univers
là c'est peut-être un petit peu beaucoup
limité avec des manchots mais il existe
un homme qui peut faire un chef louis en
projection astrale un homme qui a
traversé les dimensions pour vous livrer
ses plus grands secrets de manipulation
alors moi j'ai surtout traverser le
périph cornières tournage il existe un
homme qu'il n'a pas compris qu'on
essayait de faire la promotion du
bouquin du libre adios est tu parlais de
mon nouveau livre oui tout à fait
aménager pas compris mais du coup c'est
ton avis sincère sur simon a vu le plus
ancien mais tant mieux ça me touche
beaucoup donc lui qui a raison j'ai
sorti mon cinquième livre qui s'appelle
un petit guide de la manipulation le
mois dernier est d'ailleurs vous avez
déjà fait un très gros accueil au livre
il est bien populaire donc merci
beaucoup
ça ça fait plaisir de quoi ça parle déjà
anti guider la manipulation il ya des
indices ça parle de pourquoi la
manipulation ça existe dans le cerveau
et comment ça fonctionne la manipulation
bienveillante parce qu'on est tous
manipulateur malgré nous donc on peut
corriger ça la manipulation malveillante
mais surtout les techniques pour s'en
protéger
le but ce n'est pas de devenir donc le
chef de l'univers qui serait un peu
dictateur bref vous avez un lien dans la
description passer dessus parce que vous
allez la description du livre vous avez
le sommaire dessus ça ne vous
intéressera vous pourrez lire des
extraits il est disponible dans toutes
les librairies
et si votre libraire l'a pas il peut le
commander sur tous les sites en ligne la
fnac amazon cultura leclerc ma boutique
brainstorm les liens sont dans la
description et si vous pouvez pas
l'acheter vous pouvez l'emprunter dans
les médiathèques ou les bibliothèques ou
auprès de quelqu'un qui l'a déjà c'est
tout ce que j'avais à dire prenez soin
de vous et il existe c'est quoi tu
disais
dans les idées reçues il y a aussi les
croyances et les légendes personnel par
exemple le fameux tu de manière je suis
pas bon en maths et bien justement comme
l'expliqué thierry hdmi et sonia
pellissier ce sont des maîtres de
conférences en psychologie en physio
psychologie une idée reçue sera d'autant
mieux acceptée et ancrée dans le système
de croyances d'un individu que si celle
ci convient à notre façon de penser ou
de voir les choses et se conforment à
nos dispositions
alors faut-il être forcément bon en
maths pour réaliser un calcul incroyable
vous allez voir que amy va faire un truc
hallucinant alors qu'elle ne pense pas
encore en être capable je parle de
nombre et de chiffres et non pas parce
qu'on va parler juste avant et j'espère
qu'après deux chiffres du chiffre comme
ça c'est terrible
donc là j'ai juste peur d'être ridicule
en fait donc selon le fait de croire
qu'on a un problème avec les chiffres
c'est une idée aussi donc si j'arrive à
t'apprendre ce que je vais t'apprendre
là je lis vraiment c'est le bon goal
oui bah moi je suis un diesel je m
entends tu vois mais moi j'ai un monteur
donc après ça prend deux minutes aux
élèves toi bon on va je te fais voir le
truc d'abord j'ai juste besoin donc on
apporte une calculatrice ouvre la porte
une calculatrice comme ça il pourra
vérifier le résultat ensuite est ce que
tu peux me dire un nom donc on va on va
présenter ça un peu comme un tour de
mentalisme ok ça salut je m'appelle
faible et car shoe mentalist trop c'est
la même chose très est ce que vous
pouvez me toucher un nombre à deux
chiffres
s'il vous plaît ouais et je veux pour un
truc c'est un jeu mais bien comme ça
s'est perdu 20 vous êtes sûr ça vous
combien c'est pas vous qui allez faire
là c'est moi qui fait la démo donc
t'inquiète 25 25 27
d'accord je vais le dupliquer la
également tu vas pourquoi tout à l'heure
les tickets d'écrire deux fois
exactement on a aussi un peu de
vocabulaire et ça ça fait plaisir les
réaliser avec les mots avec les chiffres
est-ce que je peux avoir un autre nombre
à deux chiffres
ouais
12 12 ok puis moi je vais en rajouter 1
alors comme tu as été dans les bas je
vais peut-être en mettre un peu plus
costaud je m 87
ça s'est bien battu mais pas les mêmes
use d'un calcul à l'autre mouais bah
histoire de corser un peu la difficulté
maintenant le but du jeu c'est de faire
27 x 12 27 x 87 puis d'additionner les
deux résultats pour avoir le résultat
final c'est à dire ok tu le fais la
calculatrice si tu veux mais moi je veux
le corps s'est bloqué ton portable
tiens voilà j'ai fini et toi non
c'est l'étrange fabien olicard parce que
le situer le résultat c'est 2673 si tu
veux tu fais le premier j'écris de
résultats au 2e essai 324 ça c'est le
premier nom dans le premier premier tu
vois tu sais pas en fait là je te fait
trop confiance dans la vie tu vois avec
mais ça c'est bien c'est une bonne chose
et maintenant tu fait 27 morts dont
quatre à six cents égal à toi tout un
tube tu paniques toi fabien ce n'est pas
tant ces 2349 2349 et est ce que tu peux
faire 2349 plus 324 2673 pardon
metz-tessy se ressemblent à choindez 0
on va bien donc j'avais le résultat
instantanément dans moins de deux
minutes qui va être capable de le faire
et vous aussi
c'est plutôt cool non je t'explique
comment ça fonctionne
en gros tu m'as donné un nombre à deux
chiffres à 10 27
et moi je les revues cliquez ici là tu
m'as dit un autre nombre à deux chiffres
il y avait 10 12 et moi le nom qui est
là je n'ai pas écrit au hasard en fait
je les écris en complément pour que cela
fasse n'en 99 en gros comme ça me à 1
j'ai rajouté à 8 pour que parce que 8 et
1 ça fait neuf et donc le 2 1 7 pour que
ça fasse 9 et en vrai ce que je viens de
faire ses 27 x 99
si je prend l'ensemble tu vois pas ce
que 27 x 12 + 27 x 87 ses 27 4
dans dix-neuf 2700 -27 en gros ont fait
27 x 100 - 27 pour que ça fasse bien x
99 hockey et ça c'est chiant à raconter
il ya beaucoup plus simple c'est 27
tu enlèves 1 ça fait 26 et après tu
refais pareil tu fais en sorte que ça et
ça ça fasse 9 et que ça et ça ça fasse 9
ok alors regarde deux cette personne n'a
paniqué non très bien on va bien se
passer dans son cerveau 2 7 5 et 9 6 et
3 adacore exactement donc en gros j'ai
pris lui je les 1000 à -1 27 c'est
devenu 26 et ensuite j'ai juste complété
pour sa phase 9 et 9 par exemple qu'un
autre exactement c'est tout à fait le
principe c'est pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup
de petits panneaux pour toi aujourd'hui
la la c'est pas encore ton vrai test
mais sait-on training d'accord je veux
dire ben émis moi je vais mettre
d'accord 86 donc on le met deux fois en
dessous je mets quoi 72 et du coup
qu'est ce que je mette de l'autre côté
alors attends donc tu mets 3 13 99 de
l'ua de lui tu temps exact ça fonctionne
par ligne exact inverse hockey est donc
là la multiplication la multiplication
et le résultat de ces deux là de plus en
plus ça ne veut nous faire combien au
final et bah du coup alors tu fais 85-85
exacte et ensuite tu fais un oui et une
fillette c'est exactement ça tu vas
vérifier coutume quoi donc maintenant tu
vas me le faire à 0 et en fait tous les
deux non je suis un spectateur je veux
17 9 17 x 68
ok donc là je réécris 17 et là du coup
il faut alors c'est à l'an 2010 les
spectateurs laisse moi dans l'illusion
de la magie m'emmerde pas déjà 138 des
matches battant donc ça fait trente et
un jeu fait 16
non c'est 65 c 16 16
et là du coup je mets à 8 et là je mets
un endroit c'est à dire que quand même
émis blague à part en moins de deux
minutes tu es capable de faire la somme
de 2 multipliant en étant sûr de ton
résultats alors moi j'ai une vraie
question par contre pourquoi on apprend
passé à l'école bah c'est ma question
alors j du coup j'ai dit on à quel
l'apprendre sur youtube dans les wagons
mais c'est dingue non mais c'est un vrai
sujet c'est quand même c'est pas trop
bien et en vrai je crois que si on
apprenait des truc fun comme ça l'est
comme ça réconcilie un peu avec les
masses à un sujet que je pourrais tenir
déjà parlé donc idées reçues les
chiffres ne sont pas tes amis et une
idée reçue ils peuvent être des amis
ouais et vraiment je suis très bon
exemple n'a vu la panique dès ce soir
c'est quand même l'anniversaire de ton
chien j'espère que l'europe a tu vas
défaire alors attendez je vous le fais
on va faire une double multiplication
chiffres là vous vous dites sûrement oui
ok mais là fabien on est sur du
mentalisme de spectacles ganas cus du
coup moi aussi je peux le faire très
facilement
alors vous avez raison cette astuce elle
porte un nom très spécifiques
elle s'appelle les mathématiques mais
votre cerveau vous manipule au point de
ne pas vous montrer qu est ce qui est
vraiment magique dans cette histoire
c'est que en faisant des maths
vous avez l'air d'être fort en maths
parce que moi au final je vous ai appris
les règles que je tiens d'un magicien
passionnés des maths qui s'appelle harry
lorraine donc je vous recommande
d'ailleurs les livres et avec ses règles
vous pouvez trouver les résultats d'un
calcul c'est exactement la définition de
caisse que sont les mathématiques mais
l'idée reçue que les maths ça n'est pas
pour vous et que c'est forcément
ennuyeux et c'est tellement ancré dans
votre cerveau que vous avez dissocier le
tour des mathématiques
pourtant c'est la même chose alors
pourquoi ces idées reçues s'accroche et
comment est-ce qu'on se débarrasse
d'elle et nous
voyance et bien on voit ça juste jeter
pose plus fun dans sa matière grise ça
va être à vous de jouer
je vais donner à amy et avoue des
affirmations vous devrez me dire si
c'est vrai ou si c'est faux dans les
commentaires par exemple évidemment il y
aura des pièges vous êtes prêts c'est à
vous on passe au site a voulu c'est à
vous c'est toujours la troisième
expérience de matière grise et en gros
je vous pose des questions à toi ainsi
qu'a ta team viewer qui nous regardent
la vidéo et vous me répondez juste ou
pas aujourd'hui c'est un peu différent
on va faire un vrai ou faux je pose des
affirmations et comme on est un peu dans
le domaine de l'idée reçue pour voir
comment ça s'accroche comment ça tiens
comment s'en défaire on va passer des
choses il ya des choses vraies des
choses fausses il ya des pièges et tu
vas argumenté première affirmation le
prénom de césar était jules est ce que
c'est vrai ce que c'est faux il ya un
truc de manipulation terrible c'est que
déjà quand pose la question qui se pose
la question
bah oui ça doit être fou mais peut-être
qu'il allait dire qu il dise ya alors du
coup c'est vrai le fait qu il le relève
je dois en pensez quoi
et laissez-moi tranquille j'ai envie de
dire non
alors pourquoi non parce que tu me poses
la question ni kératine question que je
te connais
ça fait pas très rond - temps où il
fallait les dissocier puisque césar en
fait y en a eu plusieurs
donc déjà fallait très bonne piste ça
déjà d'accord et ben est ce que c'est le
titre en fait et c'est donc c'est à dire
les mots plus simples que les chinois
donc c'est foulée le raisonnement il est
bon en fait césar c'est un clan et jules
c'est la branche non c'est jules c'est
le clan et césar c'est la branche du
plan et son vrai prénom c'est caius donc
là cailloux ça nous ferait astérix et
obélix on est d'accord et moi en émoi
bravo deuxième affirmation l'arc en ciel
à cette couleur
alors on parle pas des des nuances de
teintes et ou dans les couleurs primes
et un majeur de l'arc en ciel
est ce que l'arc en ciel à bien cette
couleur mais les couleurs primaires
fiche
ouais ouais mais c'est l'arc en ciel ses
couleurs principales notes de lumière
oui alors qu'on le décompose ce prisme
il ya combien de couleur 7 ça me choque
pas 7 on dirait que c'est vrai eh bien
tu as bien fait de le dire parce que
c'est faux et ça me permet d'en partir
très bien et cela en vrai tu as toujours
appris qu'il y avait cette couleur à la
france yens ça c'est vrai il ya même un
moyen mnémotechnique de pour le retenir
je vous le dis ça s'appelle le vide du
genre si tu te retiens ça tu retiens les
couleurs de l'ordre de la laurentienne
donc on a même appris sable pour
certains à l'école tu vois donc on sait
que ces 7es d'ailleurs oui donc hop au
lit car les cas pas du tout mais avec ce
cru au sli barreau riccardi car c'est
newton qui a dit qu'il y avait cette
couleur parce que c'est lui qui a
décomposé la première fois la lumière
est en réalité il en a compté 6 mai
newton
il pensait que c'était un chiffre
magique et toi qui connais bien les
comptes on sait que c était très présent
pour jeunes et sept nains mais cette
femme de barbe-bleue les sept mers etc
les sept merveilles du monde donc il est
dit 6 pas où je vais rajouter l'indigo
et donc l'indigo un peu superstitieux
finalement ouais c'est complètement sûr
participer et comme quoi on peut être
scientifique et injecter de la
superstition au point qu'aujourd'hui en
2021 on croit encore qu'il ya ces deux
couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel y en a que 6
du town nous a chié dans les bottes donc
six couleurs et pas cette mais ça on n'y
reviendra plus tard parce que la
quatrième expérience celle d'après on va
créer un arc
l ensemble troisième affirmation l'homme
descend du singe
alors ça c'est la grande question c'est
un peu grosse question m qui était en
premier le jeu peut pas prétendre à des
théories qui sont hyper hyper
convaincante oui sur l'évolution alors
beau jeu c'est pas mal ta réponse étant
un peu en zigzag
ça passe à peu près à travers les
gouttes donc ça me précédemment
ces deux patrons à dire mais toujours
s'en sortir a aimé le spectacle et tu
avais une belle énergie littéralement
l'homme descend du singe et fin en tant
que tel même si on swiss suisse oui on
sait tous ce rouleau zaghouan et c'est
même là c'est ce que parce que il ya des
primates humains et des primates non
humains ce sont bien deux branches des
évolutions différentes
on est en effet frangins dans le côté
primates mais ce ne sont pas des singes
qui sont devenus des humains en fait on
a juste le chaînon manquant qui nous qui
nous fait passer de nos ancêtres aux
primates humains et aux primates non
humains mais on descend pas du singe le
singe c'est vraiment une branche des
primates a pas donc c'est faux les roues
sont ils en train de disparaître de la
population c'est un truc qu'on lit de
plus en plus en tout cas dans les
magazines alors lié au fait que c'est un
gène qui était pas fréquent et que ce
gène en plus a tendance à se faire
manger tu vois par les autres gènes donc
en fait il ya pour te dire le chiffre
qui a 2 % de la population kerrous donc
on dit que dans les prochaines années
les roues vont disparaître est ce que
c'est vrai ou pas mais c'est comme le
blanc aussi mais c'est vrai c'est un
faible aussi
c'est un noeud c'était assez imposé 1-2
du bit
ouais oui on dirait que tu as envie qui
n'est ce pas bah ouais c'est un truc que
j'aime pas quand les gens disparaissent
alors ils vont pas disparaître mais pour
le coup je les noter donc ces fausses
gelé noté parce que vraiment je le lis
souvent dans la presse d'un des articles
de presse
normal jeudi mais c'est pas possible d
une telle bêtise me gêne des roues et un
gène récessif
ce qui veut dire que tu peux être ou
avoir un enfant qu'est part au quart à
lui-même un enfant sa part on ya des
jumeaux dans une famille d axa m'en
sortais des jeunes exactement ça peut
passer deux trois quatre générations
avant deux seront manifestées donc il va
pas y avoir une explosion des roues sur
la planète terre mais par contre ce gène
lab va pas disparaître parce qu'on va en
corse le transmettre très longtemps est
ce que quand on touche un crapaud ça
donne des verrues on m'a dit ça tout
pendant france ah bon tu as dis ça c'est
une idée au dessus de chez moi c'est au
jardin vous c'est une vie paraît que
kouassi t'embrasse un crapaud il ya un
super mec qui sort c'est ce que tu as
essayé
oui raté c'est des fois quand on
embrasse un mec à la fin tu t'aperçois
que ces ingrats parce que c'est un grave
j'ai bu beaucoup d'alcool ce soir là
j'aimerais mieux qu'on n'en parle pas de
nom faux faux exact parce que tu
commençais à comprendre qu'elles sont
toutes fausses mais oui je te vois pas
complètement tort
donc ça c'est faux c'est pareil mais en
vrai c'est un truc qu'on entend beaucoup
en campagne en tout cinq tous assez pour
empêcher les enfants d'y toucher tout
simplement un mince tout ça alors tu en
as qui vraiment de fonder ryan a dit
denis ne voit là la peau mais sinon tu
peux même embrassés pour le coup un
crapaud donnera pas de bouton ça dépend
des types de crapauds nombreux drapeaux
vous avez écrit bepa 1 comme non mais il
faut le consentement du crapaud sur son
superbe à oui c'est ça écrire quand même
ainsi alors ça c'est un truc qu'on
entend beaucoup c'est le genre le
cerveau est complètement formés à la
naissance pas dans le sens formé en tant
qu'organe et d'un sens on a tous nos
neurones à la naissance et si on les
abîmes
après on en aura plus cacahuètes
c'est vrai que cette fois mais j'ai
tendance à dire non sachant qui se
construit vachement surtout petit nom
oui la neurogénèse on continue à
construire des neurones durant notre
enfance et même il ya des études encore
en cours mais on s'aperçoit que toute
notre vie on fabrique qui créent des
neurones moins qu'avant mais quand on
dit en euros de perdu tu vois tu vas
genre après une cuillère de justice
il l'a fait après une cuite tu sais on
dira alors là c'est on a perdu dix mille
neurones et ou non c'est faux bravo bas
toute la bravoure et elle avait
pratiquement tout bon alors oui je sais
tout était faux en réalité il est très
difficile d'activer son esprit critique
pour se dire ben là je ne sais pas
vraiment ce qu'on a toujours entendu
dire autour de nous fait office de
réalité pour notre esprit surtout que
parfois ben on a bon c'est ce qu'on
appelle le syndrome de l'horloge casser
une horloge cassé elles donnent leur
correctement deux fois par jour et ça ça
contribuer à ancrer dans notre esprit
que ben c'est pas si faux notre mental
préfère se rappeler des expériences qui
était correct plutôt que toutes les fois
où ça ne m'était pas voyons maintenant
pourquoi les idées reçues s'accroche et
surtout comment on s'en débarrasse
[Musique]
une idée aussi au reste pour plusieurs
raisons solidement attachés à notre
cerveau déjà parce que en général à des
simples et amusantes donc et elle
s'attache à nous malgré nous parce
qu'elle ne subisse pas le filtre de
l'esprit critique tant elles nous
paraissent logiques de base c'est pour
cette même raison qu'il est si dur de
s'en débarrasser surtout quand le reste
de la société a également adopté cette
même idée reçue ça devient une vérité
les études ont montré que la charge
émotionnelle d'un savoir erronée est le
facteur principal d'une croyance pour
lutter contre elle il faut donc faire
quelque chose que notre cerveau des
tests mais vraiment déteste c'est une
remise en question
il va falloir admettre que l'on s'est
trompé depuis des années il faut ensuite
mettre en place une barrière à l'entrée
donc simplement faire preuve d'esprit
critique la plupart du temps d'aller
vérifier soi-même l'information et
surtout de se dire je crois mais je ne
suis pas sûr plutôt que d'affirmer des
choses que l'on croit parfois savoir
d'ailleurs on va vérifier si cette
histoire d'arc en ciel à six couleurs
est vrai ou pas pour ça nous sommes
allés vérifier dans la littérature
scientifique mais on va faire
ce que ça on va le faire en créant nous
mêmes un arc en ciel comme celle là on
aura une preuve ça va toi voici ton
matériel pour créer des arcs en ciel
alors à temps j'essaie de me réactiver
le cerveau sur l'école si normalement ça
en fait ça va démultiplier la lumière
non c'est l'os et ça il ya un truc que
tu dis tu
la lumière en fait foi la fractionner
exact ça c'est très bien donc alors je
mettrai le miroir au fond de l'eau non
c'est pas ça en vrai c'est pas mal mais
pas entièrement
il faut qu'il soit un peu au blick par
rapport à l'eau en fait si tu veux avoir
un impact
la stat us a atteint je vais chercher je
cherche je cherche à tu vois là là j'ai
un truc là ok mais nous on veut qu'ils
sortent l'arc en ciel
il faut que justice alors attends
attends attends est ce que tu attends
attends je panique pas calme toi à
fabien je veux tu as tu restes tu
transpires à biot était excédé l'alors
réclame pas vous lâcher en fait faudrait
faut que je reflète quelque part mais on
n'est pas bien on n'était pas qu'on
n'est pas bon mais c'est l'idée non il
faut que ton face aux impasses donc dans
l'eau pour aller viser la partie
inférieure du miroir ok tu vois et après
tu récupères pour le coup avec ta
feuille absolue récupère quand truc
parce que tu là là et là tu là oui celui
des faibles mais là il est très jeune il
est très jaune est ce qu'on peut le
nuancer un petit peu là c'est parce
qu'il va bien pas trop mal à six voies
du violet mais pas sur le plus bel
arc-en-ciel dans un truc mais en vrai
moi de là je les vois toutes les
couleurs du latin denis
wen aussi à annonay un peu le viol et le
voit un peu oblique et un peu mieux
comme ça là c'est peut-être un peu mieux
ah je le vois bien là le bail l'entrée
milieu là l'ultra violet là je regarde
fait les nuances avoir fait des tests
c'est pas mal à cette embellie policard
envrion ouais c'est pas mal je sais pas
je t'ai pas suivi je serai ton premier
arc en ciel peut-être un des proches au
nobu cet été dans les prochaines heures
avec un petit saut deux d'or j'aimerais
beaucoup
bravo il me bat bravo doit alors ça on a
fait un arc en ciel a fait grand chose
on n'est pas sûr sur l'expérience la
plus dingue en terme de préparation à
faire mais mais pour de vrai vous pouvez
essayer de faire ce genre d'expérience
là tout bête c'est à dire les
expériences qu'ont fait newton ou des
gens comme ça à l'époque faut se dire
que même un matos comme ça il avait pas
c'est quand le mec qui est en tort
chaoui bah si ça ils n'avaient pas bien
c'est le miroir flexible qu'ils ont fait
à la lampe torche comme ça à l'époque de
newton bien sûr et le commander sur
amazon je trouve tous les gros font
partie de basket dieudonné internet a
fait mais ça paraît pas qu'on ait pas ce
que toi tu m'énerves tustet ce pouvoir
sur les gens âgés dans les points tu
peux emporter cet arc en ciel avec toi
regarde il est il a imprégné cette
feuille il te portera chance toute ta
vie grâce à mon livre offrait des
cadeaux nul que les gens aiment bien oui
ça y est un manipulateur bienveillant le
thé chez les personnes toxiques
merci beaucoup et me mercier allait on
est on va passer à la suite de la vidéo
mais dans quelques jours sors ton
nouveau court métrage qui s'appelle
portman mais je sais pas si c'est un
courant c'est peut-être un truc très
moyen la fiction
certains films et dans quelques journées
dans quelques jours sorte à fiction
certes allemagne sur sa chaîne youtube
et il y aura le lien dans la description
une fois qu'il sera sorti
en attendant y aura la chaîne mais si
vous voyez cette vidéo par exemple genre
en juillet et qu'il est déjà sorti il ya
le lien direct à la description vous
êtes un peu je me suis
jan hus cailloux merci à tous les
participants à toute l'équipe à fannie
et jérémie à la production à loïc à la
réalisation avec évidemment toute son
équipe est bien sûr à amy ltr n'hésitez
pas à découvrir ces vidéos le lien est
en bas dans la description vous pouvez
partager cette vidéo
lalique et vous abonner c'est gratuit à
cette chaîne je parle si ça vous plaît
et vous avez également tous les épisodes
précédents les huit dans la description
avec également une playlist alors
pouvons-nous dompter nos cerveaux sommes
nous capables de faire le tri dans ce
qu'on apprend pouvons-nous devenir des
vrais puits de connaissances sur nous
verrons tout cela et bien plus dans les
prochains épisodes de matière grise à
très bientôt
ciao